et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés marc semo du journal le monde
dont jean-marc jour et gauthier rybinski
notre chroniqueur internationale à
france 24 au 21e jour de l'invasion
russe moscou a pour la première fois
rendu public son exigence pour parvenir
un possible compromis avec le cren que
le pouvoir ukrainien adopte la
neutralité sur un modèle de type suédois
ou autrichiens écouter sergueï lavrov
j'espère vraiment que cette envie de
négocier
qui n'est pas encore là mais qui
commence à se manifester va prévaloir
cela donne de l'espoir pour que nous
puissions nous mettre d'accord sur nos
problèmes s'il est clair que le simple
fait de déclarer la neutralité et
d'annoncer des garanties constituerait
bien sûr un progrès notable
les blocages sont toutefois bien plus
important
refus ferme de la présidence ukrainienne
elle n'entend pas se faire dicter sa
politique par moscou marc semo vous vous
comprenez le refus l'ukraine malgré le
péril de l'invasion oui si vous voulez
l'ukraine en 1994 qui est une puissance
nucléaire la troisième après les états
unis l'union soviétique et la russie
donc hérité d'une partie avait accepté
de renoncer à ses armes nucléaires comme
le voulaient les américains en échange
de garanties de son intégrité
territoriale et ce qui était de fait un
statut de neutralité à l'époque
80% de la population ukrainienne était
contre toute idée d' adhésion à l'otan
et cela a été comme ça jusqu'en 2014
quand après la révolution maidan
l'arrivée de réformistes pro européen au
pouvoir leur désir de rentrer dans
l'union européenne et on ne parlait pas
encore de temps l'époque
la russie a annexé la crimée a commencé
la rébellion tora
attiser la rébellion dans le dos de base
et à ce moment là seulement les
ukrainiens ont réellement commencé à
devenir de plus en plus majoritaire en
faveur de temps donc aujourd'hui la
neutralité elle sera garantie par quoi
il ya un précédent et on peut comprendre
que des ukrainiens soit extrêmement
méfiant et demandent des garanties les
plus solides possibles et une garantie
d'engagement et c'est parce qu'ils ont
fait cette expérience ils ont été 2 fait
neutre après qu'il soit sorti de l'union
soviétique donc de quoi parlons nous
c'est une proposition qui d'une certaine
façon si la situation n'était aussi
tragique pour ff erreur quasiment rire
tellement c'est dérisoire proposition
dérisoire piège que que tant la russie à
l'ukraine de tir et vince qui
s'est compliqué parce que effectivement
il y à ce précédent dont par les marques
il y à la proposition qui parle de
modèles soient suédois soit autrichien
mais qui sont très particuliers dans
l'histoire l'autriche était un moyen
pour elle de recouvrer enfin d'avoir la
totalité de son territoire sinon l
époque elles étaient menacées de
scissions que deux partitions comme l'a
été l'allemagne bon simplement pour vers
les a pas empêchés d'intégrer au final
l'union européenne d'ailleurs manqué
tout à fait et d'ailleurs même de jouer
un rôle qui était important puisque dans
les années 70 80 les les chanceliers
kreis qu'ils innovâtes sont endettés ont
servi de places d'accueil pour les par
exemple des tractations
israélo-palestiniennes mais la question
n'est pas du tout la même en ce sens que
l'objectif de vladimir poutine et c'est
peut-être comme ça qu'on peut
interpréter cette proposition consiste à
non pas d'occuper en permanence
l'ukraine ce qui serait compliqué pour
lui mais de s'assurer qu'il y ait un
pouvoir à kiev qui respecte
les préoccupations de sécurité oui non
qui respecte surtout le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas de contagion démocratique entre
l'ukraine et la russie que la population
russe ne se disent pas un jour tient ce
qui est fait à l'ukraine en matière
sociale en matière économique en matière
de libertés politiques c'est mieux que
chez nous et là il ya peut-être
effectivement un moyen d'essayer de 2
pour les russes de tordre la chose mais
c'est extrêmement compliqué parce que
effectivement la direction ukrainienne
ne peut que refuser et qui serait
effectivement le garant de cette
neutralité parce que ce n'est pas qu'une
neutralité en termes de diplômes à 6 et
une neutralité politique
qui pourrait être atteinte et dont je
voudrais même pas venir écouter serre
que sur cette proposition couvre la
volonté d'une torsion politique de la
bhl l'ukraine de ses habitants et de sa
direction faire cette proposition
aujourd'hui marque ça nous dit paul la
position russe dans cette affaire que
l'invasion est plus compliqué que prévu
qu'il faut offrir une perspective
politique aujourd'hui de négocier qu'ils
ont des deux côtés on voit qu'il y a un
peu des timides ballon d'essai après
tout est dit ce qu'il veut même a dit
que la question de l'otan il y fait ils
iront c'est en même temps pas question
d'accepter cette espèce de neutralité
bringuebalante on ne voit pas garantie
par qui vu les précédents mais des deux
côtés il y a effectivement des débats
lors des sornettes on a l'impression
qu'on rentre dans un cycle où on va
commencer à négocier alors l'ukraine on
comprend très bien c'est quand même
le pays est dévasté c'est extrêmement
violent à long terme c'est quand même
très compliqué côté rhuys effectivement
l'opération s'avère beaucoup plus
compliqué que prévu mais en même temps
des choses très étranges d'avant on
aperçoit que les russes ont quasiment à
peine utilisé leur aviation alors que
c'est un de leurs points forts en syrie
ils ont massivement utilisé l'aviation
là les bombardements convoi tepa des
bombardements d'avions ce sont des
missiles donc
comment expliquer ça qu'est ce que ça
veut dire est ce que c'est parce que les
russes
ne veulent pas encore mener une guerre
totale c'est pas mal de questions que
l'on ce que l'on peut se poser mais
effectivement l'opération ce qui est sûr
ne partage absolument pas comme
l'imaginait au début la députée où il
pensait en trois jours
renverser le président voir le tout il
arrêtait la population ukrainienne
saluant les libérateurs etc etc il était
dans une espèce de fiction alimenté par
ses services par ses propres projections
bon évidemment ça ne s'est pas passé
comme d'où les réorganisations
d'ailleurs y compris au sein du sfb
d'organisation d'où le fait que
maintenant bah oui la guerre est prévu
pour être très longue les sanctions
quand même un effet très fort notamment
au niveau financier et donc
effectivement on peut se demander que si
imaginer que poutine cherche malgré tout
d'autres solutions la russie a besoin de
négocier gauthier ça découle de ce que
vous venez de dire elle a besoin de
négocier tant qu elle s'apercevra
qu'avancer n'est pas aussi évident moi
je ne crois pas à une position
fondamentalement favorable négociations
de la part de vladimir poutine ni même
de ces vieilles lavrov parce que il y a
comme le disait marc semo à l'instant il
y à 7 tours d'ivoire dans laquelle non
seulement poutine mais son pouvoir sont
enfermés et qui consiste à croire ce que
l'on veut croire et comme de l'autre
côté de la chaîne ceux qui sont chargés
de pouvoir en informations le hall la
magistrature suprême ne disent que ce
que le magistrat suprême veut bien
entendre il y à là quelque chose qui de
toute manière ne peut que renforcer une
volonté très forte et on en a parlé ici
sur cette antenne mais tout le corpus
idéologique qui entourent vague auquel
adhèrent vladimir poutine est capital
dans ce domaine là il ne se limite pas
évidemment à une négociation fut-elle
même si on l'espère extrêmement
salutaire il se limitera pas à ça c'est
dans ce contexte en tout cas beau lot
d'imagés lance qui lui a acclamé aux
etats unis une aide militaire d'urgence
ecoutez-le c'était devant le congrès
américain par visioconférence
nous devons protéger le ciel ukrainien
pour protéger les citoyens et ainsi la
russie ne pourra pas continuer à
terroriser nos villes libres si c'est
trop demander eh bien nous proposons une
alternative
vous savez de quel système de défense
aérienne nous avons besoin
nous
nous avons besoin d'une aviation
puissante pour protéger notre peuple
notre terre notre liberté
ainsi vous pourrez aider les ukrainiens
vous pourrez aider l'europe
à la réponse américaine n'a pas tardé
joe biden annonce l'envoi de drones et
de systèmes de défense antiaériens à
longue portée faute de pouvoir garantir
cette zone d'exclusion aérienne marc
semo le signe d'une certaine confiance
dans la capacité de résistance des
ukrainiens oui surtout le fait que
garantir une zone d'exclusion aérienne
avec des avions de l'otan pour faire
simple c'est la troisième guerre
mondiale donc là on va loin au livre des
drones quand même mon livre on les voit
le jour sur cette espèce de ligne de
crête entre qui n'est pas une coupe
belligérance au sens du droit
international on est toujours sur cette
ligne de crête c'est extrêmement délicat
c'est comme d'une certaine c'est d'une
certaine façon faire la guerre dernier
la guerre sans à faire formellement
voilà c'est extrêmement subtile mais il
n'y a pas d'autre solution alors
évidemment c'est une ce qui utilise son
arme qui avant tout la pression
d'opinions publiques c'est un
extraordinaire acteurs c'est aussi un
conflit qui plus encore que tous les
autres a lieu près qui l'avait précédé à
lyon en direct 1 on ait envie d avec des
moyens très léger on voit là on est en
direct qui s'adresse directement au
congrès comme il l'avait fait la chambre
des communes comme il avait fait au
parlement européen est évidemment avec
des images derrière on a vu aussi et
c'est donc ce extrêmement fort hier la
pression de l'opinion publique va jouer
et on peut imaginer que si le conflit
des rats petit virus utilise par exemple
des armes chimiques la pression de
l'opinion publique deviendra extrêmement
forte hier c'était les premiers
ministres polonais tchèque et slovaquie
s'était rendu à kiev malgré les
bombardements comment expliquer gauthier
cet acte de bravoure alors que ni joe
biden ni emmanuel macron à ne se sont
rendus bien que sollicité par le pouvoir
ukrainien dans les jours qui ont précédé
l'invasion alors ce ne peut être un acte
de bravoure comme vous dites que
justement si on mesure ce déplacement à
l'aune du refus le déplacement
demagny emmanuel macron de joe biden
pour le reste cette initiative elle est
devant elle et je crois qu'elle
correspond à un coup de communication
qui marche bien pour des premiers
ministres parce que vous avez oublié il
y a également jaroslaw kaczinsky qui est
le maître à penser de l'idéologie
polonaise ultraconservatrice qui a fait
le déplacement lui aussi bon si on
compte kaczinsky
jan chan le premier ministre slovène et
moraves yates qui le premier 10 polonais
on a quand même une brochette 2 allez on
va dire pour être gentil de pieds
nickelés de l'europe de l'union
européenne c'est à dire des gens qui ne
sont absolument pas convaincu
d'ordinaire du bien fondé de ce que les
valeurs européennes prétendent être bien
donc c'est eux qui font ce déplacement
que peuvent-ils dire à zelensky sydney
effectivement il ya eu un mouvement de
solidarité qui nécessaire mais qui est
beaucoup moins important que qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de bois que l'aurait eu
par exemple une démarche d'un d'un
chancelier allemand d'un président
français est encore plus d'un président
américain mark bray pas d'accord non on
va d'abord c'est effectivement triste
que l'europe soit représentée d'une
certaine façon par ces leaders
populistes notamment y en a et on va
essayer mais voilà ils ont le mérite d'y
aller ce sont des pays qui de par leur
histoire la slovénie ex république
yougoslave
la république tchèque qui était longue
glacis soviétique
la pologne
qui savent de quoi ils parlent donc oeil
ont été de leur propre initiative
c'est symboliquement important et on
regrette non seulement que macron le
président français qui avait été invité
trois fois avant la guerre à l'automne
il soit pas allé on peut regretter que
le comble mais la réunion des 27 à
versailles moment symbolique s'il en est
mais pas eu le courage au moins dans les
mots et dans les symboles d'un geste
fort dire mais l'ukraine fait partie de
la famille européenne comme la moldavie
et la géorgie c'est risible oui on sait
qu'ils font partie de la famille romaine
ils sont même au conseil de l'europe
rayon circuit dont il ya des moments les
gestes forts les symboles qu'on oui
terrible par ces régimes bien la cloche
qui est incarnée à kiev oui aux gens
voilà l'europe merci se marque merci
marc semo merci également à gauthier
rybinski d'avoir été avec nous pour on
va plus loin on se retrouve dans sept
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous
ah